FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, TUCKER.
TUCK PARTICULAR ANDY
>>CK PARTICULAR ANDY
>> T PARTICULAR ANDY
>> TucARTICULAR ANDY
>> TuckeTICULAR ANDY
>> Tucker:CULAR ANDY
>> Tucker: ALAR ANDY
>> Tucker: ANDR ANDY
>> Tucker: ANDY ANDY
>> Tucker: ANDY MNDY
>> Tucker: ANDY MCCY
>> Tucker: ANDY MCCARTHY ONE
OF THE MOST ELOQUENT WRITERS
ON LAW AND JUSTICE THERE IS
ANDY, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON ASSESS THESE
CHARGES IF YOU WOULD AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BROUGHT
CHARGES WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THE BROADER
INVESTIGATION.
DO THESE CHARGES BRING US
CLOSER AS AMERICANS TO
UNDERSTANDING HOW OUR
DEMOCRACY WAS HACKED IN
2016?
>> NO.
I THINK THE TAKE AWAY,
TUCKER, WITH DUE RESPECT TO
MR. STONE AND THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY IMMENSE IMPORTANCE
TO HIM TO THE COUNTRY THIS
SET OF CHARGES UNDERSCORES
WHAT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN
OBVIOUS FOR A YEAR AND THAT
IS THAT THERE NEVER WAS A
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE KREMLIN TO
COMMIT ESPIONAGE.
SOMETHING OBVIOUS TO
INVESTIGATORS FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
AND THIS LATEST SETS OF
CHARGES INDICATES THAT THEY
NOT ONLY WERE NOT IN
CO-HOOTS WITH RUSSIA, THEY
DIDN'T ACTUALLY KNOW WHY
WIKILEAKS HAD AS YOU POINTED
OUT IN YOUR INTERVIEW WITH
STONE THERE IS NO CHARGE IN
THE INDICTMENT THAT STONE,
WHO IS FACING SEVEN FELONY
CHARGES WAS IN ANY KIND OF A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY WITH
WEEKS.
ALL THIS
WIL THIS
WIKITHIS
WIKILEIS
WIKILEAKS.
ALL THIS IS ABOUT IS THE
PROCESS OF INVESTIGATING THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA CONSPIRACY
WHICH IT SEEMS TO ME NOT
ONLY DIDN'T EXIST BUT THEY
HAVE LONG NONA IT DIDN'T
EXIST.
>> Tucker: I'M FIXATED ON
THE CNN TAPE OF THIS RAID ON
STONE'S HOUSE THIS MORNING
BECAUSE, I THINK LIKE A LOT
OF PEOPLE I LOOKED AT THAT
AND I THOUGHT THIS IS NOT AT
ALL THE COUNTRY THAT I GREW
UP IN OR WANT TO LIVE IN.
IF A PROSECUTOR SAYS WE GO
TO THE HOUSE OF A
66-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO WE KNOW
DOESN'T HAVE A PASSPORT OR A
GUN, WHO LIST WITH HIS OLDER
WIFE WHO IS DEAF AND THERE
ARE DOGS AND CATS AND WE
NEED 27 ARMED FEDERAL
AGENTS, EACH WITH A SIDE ARM
AND AN AR-15, IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO SAYS YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THAT'S JUST WRONG.
THAT'S OVERKILL?
WE DON'T NEED TO DO THIS?
IT'S ACTUALLY DANGEROUS?
WHY WOULDN'T ANYONE PUSH
BACK ON THAT IDEA?
>> I DON'T KNOW, TUCKER.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THIS HAS HAPPENED IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
WHEN PAUL MANAFORT, WHEN
THERE WAS A RAID ON HIS HOME
IN VIRGINIA, IT WAS ON THE
NIGHT BETWEEN TWO DAYS WHEN
HE WAS COOPERATING WITH TWO
DIFFERENT CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEES AND IT WAS UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
KNEW HIS VERY WELL RESPECTED
LAWYERS IN WASHINGTON AND
COULD EASILY HAVE CALLED UP
THE LAWYER AND SAID HERE'S A
SUBPOENA, THESE ARE THE --
THESE ARE THE ITEMS WE WANT
THERE WAS CERTAINLY NO
REASON TO DO IT THE WAY THEY
DID IT THIS SEEMS TO BE
COMPLETE OVERKILL TO TAKE
SOMEBODY WHO IS AT
SOMEBODY WHO IS BT
SOMEBODY WHO IS BEST A WHITE
COLLAR CRIMINAL IF IS HE
ACTUALLY GUILTY OF THE
CHARGES WHO HAS COMMITTED
PROCESS CRIMES AND TREAT HIM
LIKE WAS A MAFIA DAWN OR
USAMA BIN LADEN SEEMS TO ME
TO BE CRAZY.
AND THE PROOF IS IN THE
PUDDING.
IF YOU REALLY THINK THIS GUY
IS EITHER A DANGER TO THE
AGENTS WHO WERE CONDUCTING
THE SEARCH OR A RISK OF
FLIGHT, ONE THING YOU DON'T
DO IS AGREE TO LET HIM OUT
ON HIS SIGNATURE TO $250,000
BAIL BOND.
I MEAN, HE EITHER IS THIS
EVIL GUY OR HE IS NOT.
>> Tucker: KIND OF REVEALS
THE MOTIVE, DOESN'T IT?
FINALLY THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF DEBATE TODAY ABOUT HOW A
CNN PRODUCER WITH A CAMERA
WOUND UP AT THE SCENE AT
5:00 SOMETHING IN THE
MORNING.
CNN HAS AN EXPLANATION FOR
IT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE
OR NOT.
IS IT PLAUSIBLE, IN YOUR
MIND, THAT A PROSECUTOR IN
THIS INVESTIGATION WOULD TIP
OFF A NEWS ORGANIZATION?
I MEAN, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
CONDUCT A RAID LIKE, THIS
PRESUMABLY DOING IT FOR
SHOCK AND AWE.
WOULD IT BE STRANGE TO LET A
NEWS ORGANIZATION, A
SYMPATHETIC ONE KNOW.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
STRANGE TO DO THAT
PARTICULARLY UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE WAS A LOT OF
ORCHESTRATING THE MEDIA
RESPONSE HERE.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE RAID
BEGAN AT 6:00.
THE PRESS RELEASE WAS ISSUED
AT 6:17 I THINK CATHERINE
HERRIDGE SAID THIS MORNING.
SO, THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
SUSPICIOUS.
I'M ALSO AWARE OF
INVESTIGATIONS WHERE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE MEDIA FINDS OUT
THAT THERE IS SOME LEAK IN
THE INVESTIGATION.
THE MEDIA FINDS OUT THERE IS
GOING TO BE A RAID AND THE
GOVERNMENT MAKES A DEAL THAT
THEY CAN BE ON THE SCENE AS
LONG AS THEY DON'T LEAK THE
FACT OF THE RAID SO THAT
PEOPLE GET A CHANCE TO
ESCAPE.
SO, UNTIL WE KNOW ALL THE
FACTS, I WOULDN'T JUMP TO
CONCLUSIONS.
>> Tucker: NO, I'M NOT.
I'M NOT.
WHAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING IS
ITS OWN FORM OF COLLUSION I
WOULD NOTE IF TRUE.
ANDY MCCARTHY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> COLLUSION IS A VERY LOOSE